sur la scène politique française il y a
le Parti socialiste qui occupe tout le
terrain avec son congrès il y a l'UMP
qui vont devenir qui va devenir les
républicains qui occupent aussi la scène
puisque son congrès c'est dommage mais
il y a aussi le modem et on va en parler
avec Marielle de Sarnez
député européenne dois-je le dire
bonjour Marielle de sarnenez bonjour
Avant de parler de tout ça il y a un
homme hier qui a été complètement
blanchi après cinq ans de tracas de
poursuite judiciaire
il demande les excuses ce matin
notamment dans Le Figaro à ceux qui
l'ont accusé publiquement il a raison je
peux comprendre en tous les cas c'est
bien que la justice ait fait son travail
est-ce qu'on pourrait dire que
quelquefois faudrait que la justice soit
son travail plus vite sans que ça choque
les juges ce serait bien aussi ça serait
bien aussi alors les républicains ont
lieu et place de l'UMP bon c'est un
secret de polichinelle je pense que le
vote va être favorable à ce changement
ce soir c'est une bonne idée
je suis pas sûr je trouve que le mot
républicain ça a bien commun enfin moi
je suis républicaine et je suis pas une
donc voilà il y a beaucoup de gens comme
moi et je suis pas très convaincu par
leurs argumentations de dire il faut
qu'on s'appelle républicain pour
défendre la République je veux dire il
faut qu'il crée qu'ils aient leur
identité d'un parti de droite qui assume
ça vous savez moi je vais vous faire une
confidence quand il y avait le repère je
trouve ça pas si mal parce qu'au fond il
y avait un parti à droite qui s'assumait
comme tel une droite républicaine on va
dire ça faisait baisser le Front
National et puis on avait un centre
autonome là indépendant oui mais je
pense que c'était une meilleure
organisation de la vie politique est-ce
que quelque chose va changer
dans ce parti qui change de nom est-ce
que d'après vous Sarkozy sera moins
omnipotent qu'il ne l'était par le passé
vous connaissez Nicolas Sarkozy
vous vous imaginez qui va
se voilà des investir
moi partout moins
il attaque le président de la République
sortant tous les soirs il a envie de
redevenir président à la place du
président de la République
mais c'est la vie on attend François
mais heureusement et c'est bien comme ça
c'était moi parce que ils ont pas tous
la même musique
que moi de Nicolas Sarkozy je ne sens
pas
quelconque à quelconque recule chez
Nicolas
non parce que très souvent Nicolas
Sarkozy c'est son caractère ceux qui
sont pas avec lui considèrent qu'ils
sont contre lui ce qu'il y a un autre
avis que lui au fond cela il mérite même
pas d'être entendu à votre place disait
Sarkozy c'est la culture de
l'affrontement c'est un peu ça c'est moi
le cas de Alain Juppé
Alain Juppé c'est plutôt un rassembleur
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est dans la
culture de l'affrontement et moi je
crois profondément qu'il faudra je vais
le dire vite que la prochaine élection
présidentielle elle soit utile pour
qu'elle soit utile faudra réformer le
pays et pour pouvoir réformer le pays il
faudra des majorités larges et que
quelqu'un comme un jumpé il peut
rassembler des majorités larges pour
aller vite on sent que vous mettez
derrière un GPS alors nous avons dit que
nous étions absolument prêts à le
soutenir parce que moi j'ai envie de
cette élection présidentielle soit utile
au pays dans la primaire 30 ans pardon
qu'on élit les uns ou les autres des
gens de droite des gens de gauche et que
derrière il se passe rien pour le pays
aucune réforme lourde pour le pays j'ai
envie que ça change vous allez le
soutenir dans la primaire on verra
comment les primaires comment l'imprimer
est organisée
est-ce que c'est une primaire qui sera
ouverte moi je verrai je regarderai
c'est dans 18 mois 18 mois
en politique
c'est hors de question c'est une
primaire de la droite c'est ça qui est
compliqué elle est ouverte de l'UMP
ouvert ou alors le mode ouverte on verra
si elle est ouverte s'il faut aller
voter dans les permanences UMP ou si
c'est vraiment une primaire ouverte moi
je verrai mais je ferai tout ce que je
peux faire pour qu'effectivement si
Alain Juppé est en position je nous
serons à ses côtés
vous me témoin d'un doute vous êtes dans
l'opposition le modèle oui bien sûr nous
sommes opposants
nous sommes on a voté comme 4 à 5
millions de Français c'est-à-dire qu'on
n'a pas voté pour le président de la
République sortant c'est plus exact
comme ça je n'ai pas voté je n'ai pas
voté pour le sorton parce que je trouve
que son bilan n'était pas bon d'accord
alors si je pépère la primaire qu'est-ce
qui se passe vous voyez vous êtes déjà
après la primaire la primaire elle est
dans 18 mois on va essayer de faire en
sorte je pense qu'elle a Jupé va essayer
de faire en sorte de gagner cette
primaire je trouve que ça serait bien
voilà je vous dis il est pas centriste
il est d'une autre famille politique que
la mienne mais il a une capacité à
rassembler large personne ne fera croire
qu'on pourra réformer le pays là dans
les années qui viennent bloc contre bloc
en plus un bloc de droite qui est entre
20 et 25% un bloc de gauche qui est
entre 18 et 22%, tout ceci ne fait aucun
sens il faut évidemment des
rassemblements plus larges moi j'étais
giscardienne et j'étais tout à fait
favorable à l'idée de Français sur trois
pour réformer le pays d'accord ça a pas
marché
essayons de le faire maintenant c'est
nécessaire c'est utile
oui
ça me fait plaisir de le faire d'accord
alors j'ai compris que avec Alain Juppé
la droite c'est l'UMP enfin les
républicains l'UDI et le modem alors
avec Alain Juppé mais c'est les Français
d'abord écoutez moi c'est militante
enfin je suis pas pour l'esprit de
partir et que l'esprit de partir
imprègne tout je veux dire c'est les
Français qui devront faire un choix
c'est beaucoup plus large que ça on est
parti de très haut on va on va se
recentrer c'est bien de partir un peu
vers le haut
ça fait du bien l'Île-de-France pour
commencer alors est-ce que vous demandez
à Madame Jouanneau sans triste de l'UDI
de rallier la liste ou les listes de
bananes tout le monde voit bien ce qui
est en train de se passer entre l'idée
et l'UMP il y a des négociations vous
étrangez derrière l'UMP moi je suis
rangée nulle part j'ai une petite
différence avec mes amis Ludi c'est que
moi j'aime bien l'indépendance ils sont
plutôt quelquefois je trouve je ne peux
pas durgiste un peu dans la dépendance
moi j'aime l'indépendance c'est vital je
me sens mieux plus heureuse comme ça
vous voyez plus épanoui qu'est-ce que
vous préférez alors l'indépendance ça
veut pas dire qu'on fait pas de
partenariat mais moi je vais vous dire
une chose solide de France qui
m'inquiète beaucoup c'est je trouve que
c'est mal parti je trouve que là je vais
vous dire pourquoi c'est mal parti c'est
mal parti parce que j'ai le sentiment
qu'on assiste à une espèce de
nationalisation de la campagne régionale
et en particulier solide de France et
qu'on va avoir d'un côté ceux qui vont
vous dire ah ben cette campagne c'est
fait pour voter pour ou contre François
Hollande et de l'autre côté les autres
qui vont dire c'est fait pour voter pour
ou contre Sarkozy
politique je viens de vous dire vous
avez bien vu comment Nicolas Sarkozy
parle PS cool candidat PS répond enfin
on est dans une espèce de truc Hollande
Sarkozy et il trouve que c'est une
erreur moi je laisserai je ne laisserai
pas faire ça je vous le dis parce que je
sais qui est perdant dans ce genre de
truc ce sont les franciliens et j'ai pas
envie de ça je vous donne l'occasion
c'est l'occasion jamais de parler et ben
je viens de vous le dire je laisserai
pas faire ça d'accord donc vous êtes
pour Valérie bécresse je trouve que
Valérie Pécresse c'est une bonne
candidate mais je vous dis attention si
cette campagne part comme ça et que les
partis politiques
font campagne voilà est-ce que vous
pensez
pour la convaincre de rejoindre cette
unité mais écoutez vous savez tout ça
est en train de se faire moi les
affaires d'appareil politique elle
m'intéresse pas du tout et je pense que
les Franciliens alors ça les intéresse
pas non plus ce qui les intéresse c'est
à quelle heure ils prennent leur
transport en commun comment fonctionne
leur ou leur train alors justement
Rhône-Alpes on se pose la question c'est
une grande région Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
savoir comment fonctionne les transports
en commun vous savez j'ai été
journaliste là-bas non mais surtout il y
a Laurent Wauquiez qui est le candidat
le candidat supposé et surtout désigné
de l'UMP des républicains ça pas l'heure
de plaire beaucoup à l'UDI est-ce que ça
vous plaît à vous-même moi je trouve que
Michel Barnier ressemble plus à la
région je vous le dis je ressemble plus
à la région Rhône-Alpes que les
Rhône-Alpes et les Auvergnats attendent
donc nous avons un chef de fil c'est
Patrick Mignola qui est le chef des
files pour le Mouvement Démocrate et
nous verrons et nous verrons à l'automne
comment les choses vont se faire en tous
les cas c'est un homme de la savoir et
donc c'est un courageux voilà et il est
très bien il a une bonne analyse sur la
région et nous allons voir ce que nous
ferons plus une région qui risque de
rester à gauche alors non si vous êtes
tous divisés
mais tous divisés il faut se rassembler
mais il faut se rassembler quand les
choses sont compatibles donc on verra le
discours
les élections régionales c'est dans 8 à
9 mois je vous répète que j'aurais
préféré Michel Barnier que nous allons
poser nos idées que nous allons poser
nos propositions sur la table que nous
allons voir les équipes que nous
proposons et nous allons avancer comme
ça et rendez-vous à l'automne c'était le
Talk Orange de Marielle de sarnel ce qui
nous a dit deux Français sur trois avec
slogan souvenez-vous dans les années 70
de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing il faut
rassembler le modem vaccy employé
Marielle de sarnes va s'y employer avec
Alain Juppé si c'est lui qui est choisi
à l'issue de la primaire et avant cette
primaire et bien elle va tout faire pour
que ils puissent la gagner et en
Île-de-France et bien il faut comme en
Rhône-Alpes comme partout dans toutes
les régions il faut arrêter de
nationaliser ce scrutin qui nous attend
pour le mois de décembre merci